Nhanh ngăn hàng thương mại của Phần Saigon S.B.
Mui bá cải sản bà đam năm trong sang một một lì một chăm 2,
mấy mả tải sản.
Lên quan tế vụ ăn phạm thịt phát,
ngôn mấy hai bất đậm sản tế thành phố Chí Minh và tinh Ninh,
công một tải sản khác.
Lý đều là các tải sản đáo hoàn thiện phát liy thế chấp,
có thể chuyển lực độc lập và dự kế nước đưa sạch đấu sản,
sau khi hoàn tất công tất cả định sản.
S.B. mấy đỉnh sá lế bất quan trọng định sản hội điểm trước khi tổ chức đấu sản.
Qua trình sử lý tải sản lực thực hiện theo đúng người định giữ sử sử sản sát,
của các thương quan trưng năng nhà bà đam tính khách quan mình bà hợp qua thuộc nơi.
Nhìn tải, môn mấy môi trăm 2 mấy má tải sản bà đam,
đàn được sự dụng để bà đam cho một lì nơi hai chăm 1 bà khoảng vầy,
của bà chương mỹ làm tại S.B.
Vì sử lý tải sản lưu trên khai trong hai dự đoạn.
Môn lợi trọng đất định từ bán và lợi trọng đất định sản,
tổ chức đấu sản công 2 thương quí định của phó loạt.